frank herbert's june series deals with
apply to the fremen people and their
struggle to stop intergalactic overlords
from mining their planet to death the
freeman service dunes emotional center
and provide its narrative backbone this
is their story
frank herbert didn't create this desert
culture out of hulk cloth he drew
inspiration from a healthy mix of world
religions and several actual indigenous
cultures on earth in particular he
looked at the way that these peoples
managed to make a life for themselves in
places that might be considered
inhospitable herbert was compelled to
write june after hearing of a project by
the united states department of
agriculture that would stop oregon's
marching sand dunes from moving the usda
planted different kinds of grass along
the dunes to calm their movements as the
blowing sand could wreak havoc on nearby
roadways and towns thurber decided to
contrast the government's response of
changing the landscape with the way that
native people across earth have
historically learned to live in harmony
with the planet's natural processes the
empire of june came to represent these
outsiders reshaping worlds in ways that
make them more profitable while the
fremen stood in for the ideas of
harmonious living herbert based the
fremen in large parts on the sun people
who lived in the kalahari desert like
the fremen the sun learned to conserve
water in order to survive in some of the
most unforgiving terrain on earth
the fremen are descendants of a
persecuted religious group called the
zensuni wanderers this nomadic group
fled across the void of space to evade
imperial violence herbert created their
religion from the combined tenets of
sunni islam and his own belief in zen
buddhism their final stop was arrakis a
barren desert planet believed to be
worthless before the discovery of a
spice called melange he who controls the
spice controls the universe this spice
gave all who consumed it a minor amount
of prescience it quickly became crucial
for navigating ships in a galaxy that i
created faster than lights travel so the
fremen found themselves in a familiar
situation to anyone who knows about the
amazon rainforest or the so-called
american frontier they were the people
living on top of a coveted natural
resource and they suffered in similar
ways to those indigenous peoples on
earth
the fremen were viewed as backward and
savaged by dune-colonizing outsiders
their culture was an example of the ways
in which humanity can survive in the
least probable situations because of the
extreme scarcity of water on the surface
of their planet a huge chunk of fremen
culture and ritual is based around the
collection and conservation of this
vital mineral they travel the surface of
dune dressed in still suits full body
coverings i collect and filter sweat
respiratory droplets and waste and store
it in catch pockets this water is then
recycled via tubes that are pumped
through levels in the still suits heels
in this perfectly closed system not a
drop of water is wasted the freyman
conception of wealth also revolves
around the collection of water they live
in small bands that move between
underground sieges where they store
their water communally individuals wear
jewelry that symbolize their share of
the water when freymen die their bodies
are rendered in a holy ceremony and
their water is added back to the wealth
of the tribe the frey men have also
managed their cautious coexistence with
the desert's greatest threat sand worms
called makers by the fremen the massive
creatures tunnel through the desert sand
and appeared the slightest noise from
men learn at a young age how to walk
through the desert in a sliding
arrhythmic gate that mimics the natural
settling of sand they do this to avoid
drawing sand worm attention unless
they're looking to hit your right that's
right the fremen also have a strategy
for riding the sun worms of june it's a
dangerous maneuver that allows them to
cover massive stretches of the desert at
a clip this technique is a closely
guarded secret of their community
though the empire believes that they are
few in number the truth is that a
massive society has blended into the
desert my lord
i suspect an incredible secret has been
kept on this planet
that the fremen exist in vast numbers
from the safety of their underground
seizures the collected frey men have
been working on a generational
terraforming project their goal is to
eventually transform june into a verdant
and hospitable planet this secret
society of desert nomads provides an
army lying in wait for paula tradies who
assumes a freyman name muadeeb to invade
the polar port city of arakeen in the
real world muadeeb is arabic for teacher
during the epic june saga an imperial
governor on june is overthrown by a
scheming family looking to settle a
blood feud the son of that governor
escapes to the desert with his mother
the lady jessica jessica takes advantage
of prophecies that have been seeded
among the fremen by a holy order known
as the benny jesseret to which she
belongs using this missionary protective
her she coerces the fremen into
accepting her son as their messiah his
name is paula tradies but he quickly
assumes a fragment name meaning kangaroo
mouse the freyman admired this creature
for its ability to live on the surface
of june it's paul's reciprocal embrace
the feminine traditions that leads him
to the spice and the awakening of his
dormant powers of prescience without the
fremen paul and jessica might never have
survived their exile to the desert they
certainly wouldn't have been able to
mount an assault and harkonnen arakin
paul became a true messianic figure
during his time among the fremen the boy
had been trained by his mother and the
weird arts of observation perception and
control practice by the beni jesuit is
for generations this all-woman mystical
order exerts influence by subtly
moulding the genealogy of great houses
then they insert their converts into
bloodlines in the hopes of creating
their own messiah known as sequestar's
hadarak this figure will be able to
access areas of prescience that the
bennet jesuit witches could not reach
this is the place they cannot lock
in short generations of witches had
worked to eventually create a sunny
would be trained in their ways though
paul's mother had not been given the
go-ahead to train paul she trained him
anyway knowing that he would be killed
by the forces allied against their
family if he was not prescient when
these powers combined with paul's
training as a freman he became a mystic
desert dweller who could see the future
and use it to reshape dune paul then
uses an army of fremen who heard his
revolutionary message to destroy the
precious spice that facilitates all
space travel he simultaneously attacks
the empire's outpost while holding the
galaxy's spice supply hostage the
emperor is forced to cave to paul
muadeeb who becomes the undisputed ruler
of june
even though paul is revered as a god in
the flesh by the fremen history quickly
slips out of his control the reverence
and religious fervor surrounding
muwardee but transforms into a cosmic
jihad waged in paul's name it's fought
and led almost entirely by his army of
fremen fader keen warriors with the
backing of his religious order the
kizarat hundreds of wells and billions
of people come under the sway of paul's
empire in the early days of his reign a
religion grows around him and the fremen
homeworld of june becomes a kind of
space age jerusalem paul's prescience
shows him where this path is headed but
he becomes hemmed in by his future
visions and his status as the godhead so
paul is essentially paralyzed to act in
any way that might assure his peoples
enduring salvation
among the fremen there is an
undercurrent of dissent from older
veterans of paul's war who don't like
the way that fremen culture is changing
as paul makes water more available older
fremen look on in horror as the strict
codes observed by previous generations
begin to disappear in addition to that
the fader keen become disillusioned with
the war effort when they come home to
meager pensions and comfortable suburban
homes that carry little trace of the
harsh life of the siege a plus is
hatched among these fremen dissenters to
assassinate paul these rebels are egged
on by the spacing guild who have lost
their unfettered access to the spice
melange the benny jesseret witches who
have lost control over their breeding
program also encourage the revolt paul
sees these machinations in his visions
but has trouble figuring out how to
avoid the plot bearing fruit without
causing more misery ultimately he allows
himself to be grievously wounded by the
freman descenters he is blinded by a
nuclear blast near the holy city an
attack that he foresaw the strict
feminine way of life hopes that anyone
who loses their sight must wander out
into the desert and allow himself to die
rather than slowing down the tribe
though paul is an emperor and could have
carried on without his sight he sees in
his path away off the treadmill carrying
him toward the fremen's ultimate demise
in sacrificing himself pursuant to
traditional fremen law he silences the
doubts of the traditionalist hardliners
who worried that he had forgotten the
ways of the fremen
under the 3 500 year reign of paul's son
leto ii the freman culture grows faint
by merging with sand trout a kind of
larval stage of the great sand worms
lito the second becomes a nearly
immortal human sandworm hybrid he rules
long enough to realize the great dream
of lies kinds to terraform june into a
moist temperate planet lito is
ultimately killed by one of his
descendants a freman atreides named
siona who has evolved the ability to
hide from his power of foresight tiona's
assassination of lito sets off the great
scattering this is an event that sees
the many peoples of the former empire
dispersed in the galactic diaspora
without access to the spice they are
essentially isolated for thousands of
years on the planetary islands when the
peoples of the scattering return one
particularly violent sect the honoured
matrese bombards the surface of dune
with planet destroying weapons these
weapons called obliterators kill the
last remnants of the freeman
civilization in frank herbert's original
series of six novels only one freyman
escapes the scouring of june this is a
girl named shiana a name derived from
the original freyman siona and the
mainline descendant of paula tradies
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]